[Music]
in violent boyfriend news o mais
submitted by sandy loves JK Thank You
sandy beach thank you the LAPD is
investigating influencer radius for
allegedly abusing a minor whose radius'
he everyone influenced he's a youtuber
and he also came out and like he's an
actor he came out in like a slow side o
e flows high [ __ ] I could have said that
wrong I could have remembered wrong he's
in East Los College no that show the
show um anyway this is what he looks
like and this girl her name is Angelica
she's 17 years old and they would make
videos together a lot like for his
YouTube channel she's 17
she looks like a hot dog yeah she looks
like a young AC Slater he's 33 he looks
25 - so yeah he wasn't he something they
look the same age yeah but he's 33 and
she is 17 to me that doesn't seem
molesty and I'm not protecting them but
it's just when you don't know their age
they looked like a good-looking couple
that's just together yeah we do yeah I
agree she look are they together early
20s mid-20s so the thing is like they
would do videos and like him something
like I think one video or two video like
he actually made out with her but that's
that's circa like he's kind of around
they all make out with each other I
don't know but they're just pointing
this out where people started
speculating that they were dating
oh cause like lily and Tuan and all them
like they all kiss each other and [ __ ] I
don't know what group he's in but
because of that they were like what's
the [ __ ] like are you guys dating oh you
guys are together a lot he's not a photo
of him oh because people know she's 17
so they think it's quick she was high he
was saying you know it's actually a lot
Ashley Kay Fitness Oh like over a
million followers and they would come to
our gym all the time and oh boy the bees
have been to our gym yes these people
influencers both of these influence I
don't know they can't our gym yes
innocent innocent no matter what both
Enis no use accused of beating a girl
this is my gym before them
see that's the wrong part yeah so then
her again
is that after but she got beat up or
before story cuz she looks different
this chick should beat the makeup off of
her yup
a year ago he was being accused by his
ex his ex is like that he was very
abusive she beats a lot of people up huh
and like we talked verbally and
physically assaulting them and stuff and
so he ended up saying like no making up
excuses right or just getting away with
it pretty much the same like know that
that's not what happened it was a lot of
pretty guys like to beat up their
girlfriends phagon horse most recently
Angelica's mom she ended up posting on
instagrams as this clip where he is
yelling at her like crazy and he ends up
slapping her oh oh that's not good clip
like it's just the audio because I can't
see what's happening but can you hear
yes you can so I will play no play audio
that I have and on Instagram you could
only play a minute or something but
there's more so here I'll play what I
have here thank you
oh yes that's again say no again say no
again it's always me getting hurt right
it's always meaning did it hurt say yes
or no oh my god yes or no yes or no no
is it always taking a trip oh is it
always picking up that's amazing
something like that or is he snapping
early I don't know do you want this slap
and then the second one is event it's
not about you do I get hurt every time
do I have to get hurt every time love to
get hurt every time yes I do say yes
many suppliers
what's that liar this is just like
people and yeah so the mom like found
this recorded it so the mom posted this
on Angelica's Instagram way so who was
recording this Angelica oh so she's the
mom somehow came across it I don't know
how but the mom caught it and she posted
it on soon so she secretly recorded the
argument Angelica hmm so then when that
came out Angelica
Rhett so like she had ran away and the
mom was saying like hey you know my
daughter's missing
and she also stole her the mom's car and
then so she was saying like you know
where's my daughter kind of thing and
then like this she's in danger because
she's probably with Ray and then that's
when Angelica ended up posting a video
saying hey um that video that my mom
posted it actually was all fake it was
it was ray and I like it was like an
acting thing where we were just
practicing and like he needs to get into
it like she was telling me about it and
a past experience that he had and I was
just telling him I can't you know like
how about you use this as an acting
exercise like just just really fully
like feel like recreate the scene or
whatever they're really good actors if
they did it yeah so they were recording
that for the acting exercise she was
saying and then that's what a ray was
saying as well so the police ended up
going and searching Ray's home for her
she was missing but they didn't find her
and then that's when like drama alert
cuz he was making videos about ray like
telling LAPD to arrest him because of
all this abuse allegations and then so
after that then ray ended up posting a
Twitter video telling the keemstar like
hey you know like the cops came and look
I have a clean bill here like she's not
with me like why would she'd be with me
and all this stuff that's funny but
that's not what keep stars even talking
about yeah exactly
and he doesn't even address the other
stuff either so then after that happened
she was found and a life yes she's okay
and then she ended up going on drama
alert and doing an interview and saying
like yeah I was lying that's
they wanted me to say about the XI so he
actually cut open his box spring in his
apartment when the cops were there and
had her hide there Oh another woman like
lay on the bed so she was being like
good while the cops were there trying
like search for her she was hiding in
the box spring and then so I forgot to
bring the dogs yeah the dogs would have
smelled her in the box spring yeah how
do you even didn't yeah she's pretty
tiny I guess I mean if you fit on a bed
you fit in a box spring and then like
it's pretty big that's true yeah but
when you open it is not empty is it yeah
they're Springs like but there's
probably room anyway the point is she
was in there and then so she was saying
that um like now she's just really
afraid for her life and like she's I
don't know how she came into the light
but now she realizes that she's being
abused and stuff she's not being
manipulated by him anymore
ya know anymore so she she got away and
then she got on keemstar
and she feels like safer there um well
yeah like cuz she's back with her mom
and so she was also so keen was asking
her like well you know I kind of have to
ask you this because of your age but
like when did you guys start dating she
said about eleven months ago when she
was 16 yeah and then he was like were
you guys sexually active and she was
kind of like like shaky and her voice
and she was kind of like well you know
we were in a relationship so that kind
of answers your question kind of thing
and then it's towards the end of the
interview he's she ends up saying things
that just really made me feel yucky but
she was saying what did she say that he
was pretty much she didn't want to
become sexually active with him yeah he
would pretty much like like manipulated
her into saying like well I need you to
be a woman and if in order for you to be
a woman I want to be with a woman you
got to do this with me so like just
straight-up abusive that is kind of
weird though cuz she's 33 yeah that's so
when you look at the picture you don't
think this but then when you realize how
much of an age difference this is
internal like in this in this couple
it's like what the [ __ ] he basically
it's an age thing for sure but it's our
Kelly he's [ __ ] abuse
how is he not arrested at the race okay
I've been a risk all day LAPD did it or
like they did finally look into the the
investigators looked into the
allegations and they did arrest him but
he paid fifty thousand to get out like
his bail was like five hundred thousand
and or something like that and then
handed up paying fifty and so he's out
as like the let the latest thing that I
know is that he made bail and that
Angelika ended up posting another video
just saying how like she was crying like
she was sobbing ah she was just like
he's out was scared for my oh my god
that's sucks he's a [ __ ] but that what
the age thing points out is that he's
basically into controlling things and
manipulating right cuz it's an art
Kelley situation yeah his mom posted his
all mom his mom posted mrs. D s yeah
trying to like support him yeah
and saying like you know they're they're
just doing it for the cloud like these
women coming out come on lady I'm so
stupid
did she hear the recording right as a
woman herself like you don't this a [ __ ]
just stay back and just be baby's mom to
that you raised the boobs like you know
those little you'd see your little boy
it's like I'm in Game of Thrones with
seriously imagine and yeah Joffrey is
like it's your little boy where Tycho
was like that whoa
yeah that's true that's true as as
convincing as she is though we do have
to look at it in a way where it's like
well what part of that is real and what
part of that is exaggerated well because
there are other women that have come out
a year ago thing right I mean yeah I'm
not I'm not saying okay so here's the
problem with all of this is that you
know what the meet to movement and all
this stuff and it's like it's great that
women are being more empowered to like
talk and speak up but in the mix there
are people who get wrongly accused as
well so if we want to look at this in a
way we got to look at it how they do it
in court where it's like okay there's a
lot of things that's being said right
now but just based off of that
can we really believe everything she
should have trapped them when she hit in
the boxspring when the cops came she'd
be like yep that would have been like
she's at his home and that's home and
she's willing to hide in a box bring
she's done ready so yeah manipulated and
brainwashed the point where she feels
like because this is what he was doing
her he was telling her like you need to
protect me no one can know that we're in
a relationship because I'm gonna be in
trouble that's what he was saying in the
video like I'm always the one getting
hurt in Sochi he blamed her all the time
like for anything but police are there
right well see and what she did with the
recording is perfect like things like
that that's that's some [ __ ] good
evidence that's good evidence after you
hear that you're like oh no there's no
way she's [ __ ] making this up yeah
and I think everyone's gonna just side
with her but also it's like we have seen
a lot of crazy [ __ ] go down where people
get and like they go to jail for like 20
years
for accused you know [ __ ] like that one
football kid that his whole career with
oh yeah yeah well I mean I think it
serves as something really positive
though that if you are in this situation
regardless if it's at least for this
specific case regardless if it's fake or
not it's always good to speak up and and
find a space where you feel safe enough
for words with cops to speak up and say
something about it and the fact that she
did record it I'm like [ __ ] kudos to
you because now you have way more
evidence on your side I think it's up to
the law to now bring in all these
different things and hope
use their best judgment to be like okay
this [ __ ] guilty or this
[ __ ] like well [ __ ] is the art
le situation Jackson even they leave
they come back that's the [ __ ] crazy
part yeah and I think the real lesson is
you can't really trust guys that are too
good-looking you know that's what you
want to mention a little bit more into
the story just so you guys get the full
picture is that after the the one minute
that was posted because there's only one
minute limit there was more audio to
that to that and in that audio he
started telling Angelica to kill herself
just [ __ ] shotgun [ __ ] frame my
mom was doing yeah TV mom good only on
Instagram yeah so then um so bigger were
saying that and then Angelica saying in
her interview that she had just gotten
to the point of being so insanely
depressed yeah before she started
recording Mike she actually they were on
the freeway coming back from Coachella
and then she pulled her body halfway out
of the car cuz he was telling her like
just [ __ ] kill yourself so she ends
up like she wanted to die and he ended
up pulling her in and that's when she
started recording so she was saying like
being in that mental state and with
someone so abusive to and I'm being at
that age too is like this guy needs to
be locked up for [ __ ] ever yeah
[Music]
[Music]